why're card an online payment company
that was once the darling of Germany's
FinTech industry lost nearly 12 billion
dollars of market value and filed for
insolvency
just days after revealing a two billion
dollar hole in its balance sheet what's
happening at work are looks like being
one of the worst financial disasters in
Europe since the financial crisis of
this magnitude in Europe the missing
white hard money was supposed to be held
in two trust accounts the auditors
investigating the company said they
couldn't find it this two billion
dollars is essentially equivalent to all
the profits that wire card has made in
more than a decade
and everyone is wondering where did that
money go and nobody knows at the moment
whether it exists where there ever
existed or not here's what we know let's
rewind and start with what wire card
actually does we are a global thin tech
company with 20 years of payment
experience the German company provides
software and systems that link retailers
consumers and the financial system
so essentially what they do is they
collect sort of payment details from
people who want to buy stuff online or
even in stores they collect those
details from their cards and then they
perform the role of confirming settling
processing that whole transaction when
you buy anything online whether it be a
holiday some goods or services their
background was a lot of it was in
gambling and pornography or adult
entertainment over the years the company
began to bloom as commerce shifted
online and away from cash payments it
attracted interest from giants like
Softbank and Credit Suisse their stock
grew almost six-fold between 2016 and
2018 but some have questioned why cards
business model and whether the company
was actually worth its market valuation
and contacted me said have you ever
looked at this company with white heart
and I haven't
that's Mattel he's a short seller
meaning he tries to make money by
betting that a certain company's share
price will fall in 2016 l published a
report accusing Y card of malpractice
probably been instrumental involved in
this processing illegal gambling u.s.
u.s. basing their illegal online
gambling buys the company denied those
allegations and else has he stopped
short selling its stock some years ago
starting early last year a new wave of
Financial Times articles on the
company's global operations led to wire
card calling in KPMG for a special audit
this audit was supposed to demonstrate
that a bunch of the business that people
had said they doubted was really real
but KPMG said it wasn't able to
determine the answer to some of those
questions and one of the biggest
questions was why there was a bunch of
money supposedly in some trustee
accounts and whether that money was
really there when auditors went looking
for the two billion dollars of cash that
wire card had said was in to trust
accounts in the Philippines what they
found was a gaping hole electronic scans
of documents confirming the accounts had
been sent to Ernst & Young but its main
auditor Ernst & Young finally said that
these documents weren't reliable and
that they thought they'd been deceived
the why can't story then began to
unravel quite rapidly CEO Marcus brown
stepped down Y card said that the
missing two billion probably didn't
exist and then you haven't guessed an
armed Indian might even flushed and
faucets and then dr. Marcus brown you
mention a phenomenon of the Emir
I was veena and Erised is what he stands
accused of is inflating the value of the
company through feigning business with
these third-party acquirers Brown has
consistently denied wrongdoing and his
lawyers didn't respond to a request for
comment the partner companies in
question were supposed to process
payments for wire card in countries
where it didn't have full licenses to
operate
but it couldn't be determined whether
they generated any revenue for the
company at all in a matter of days the
company had filed for insolvency
proceedings citing over-indebtedness
matter the short seller says even if
he's not making money from wire cards
latest woes he's glad that people are
starting to see the clear picture but
there's still a big question over
whether or not that two billion dollars
actually exists why card executives have
advanced two theories one is that the
numbers were completely made-up they the
the revenue was never there and that
wire card was simply trying to inflate
the value of its business in order to
make its shares more attractive in order
to borrow more money and the other
option is that some of this business did
exist but for whatever reason it wasn't
really being done on behalf of wire
cards and the money was never put where
it was supposed to be put and in fact it
has been you know in all or in parts
taken by some other people somewhere